hello guys I'm Ryan right now in video
Danielle's eating because she's hungry
and I was like you know what really
makes for great realism when someone's
hungry and eats yeah the mics gonna pick
that up and it's gonna sound beautiful
yeah so today we're gonna watch from
Roman Atwood blowing up my kid prank if
there's one thing I love it's a good
prank
blow what not to blow blow
the cocaine drop yes gotcha there's this
guy named Archie arch it is ver meth Rex
and he wrote oh my God look how much you
wrote
I thought you wrote for you read like
five or six paragraphs all talking about
why he doesn't like the real rejects
mainly because of me this videos gonna
be dedicated to you buddy yeah blowing
up my cam prank all right here we go if
there's one thing I've ever wanted to do
and this is for you man it's blow up a
kid or at least that people believe that
I did yes me too so funny what and this
would be a sexual fetish of mine huh
hope you appreciate that buddy
hey guys today my girlfriend believes
that our three-year-old son and I are
looking at a used four wheeler she's
gonna come pick it up in our truck what
she doesn't know is that it's fully
remote control you tell mommy say I want
did you bring the check she's lost like
all that babies lady you know no I don't
I don't have to write it out - hey he's
gonna crush her
this is so much yeah
oh my god
it's not pausing it's kind of funny
oh I'm sorry oh how did she find out I
think she just picked up on the fan
right there still love me right
pranks
if you thought I was a little bit
crossing the line when it came to our
relationship Veronica oh that is so
messed up
yeah wow that is Messer she didn't seem
to really care about it was kind of
hilarious at the same time it is
hilarious but like hate to admit it but
our mother acts of interacts or whatever
your name is thinks of that like you
know what tomorrow
Roman is mind up I love how she did not
have it like she was pissed like she
knew it was a prank and she was pissed
about it did she know I think she just
picked up on I haven't seen all of his
previous pranks he's done like those
shits in her pranks see she shouldn't be
too mad because she knows what she got
into with him that he's a prankster and
Hayek's is living off that but when she
did think he wasn't she was like oh well
I think she picked up on that I think
she picked up on the fact that it was
fake right away I mean I think she went
into like she saw where the explosion
happened if she was able to see that it
was fake she should prank like somebody
who doesn't have internet so they don't
know like what's about to happen it's so
messed up how I she wasn't cool with it
and then he still posted it but I kind
of think that's funny whenever they get
to keep that little car thing
he's he's having a laugh about making
his wife miserable well you're gonna do
it some way or another
I completely understand if you do it for
YouTube yeah my girlfriend sitting right
there and absolutely I support Roman
Atwood my girlfriend sitting right there
too and I would never hurt her in that
way but if it's for the sake of YouTube
comedy you understand right I don't I
wouldn't do that to her
I honestly what she says she's done like
every other day you guys don't worry
anyway guys yeah we're good yeah trust
me anyway guys thanks for tuning in to
the Chanel called the real rejects hey
if you're new to the channel you could
be like my number one subscriber March
it is Verma Thrax he has a very small
penis that at times when it's not erect
it looks like a vagina it goes inside
the body goes inside the body that's how
small it is but you know what you stay
strong my friends girls like that too
and by girls I mean yo mama your mom I
said yo mama my mama know your mama
his mama yeah I just said he had sex
with they have this image of this dude
in my mind having sex a month no no no
won't even joke about it maybe turning
me anyway yeah you can click this button
to subscribe Danielle you can follow her
on Instagram Instagram where it's a girl
or a gallery of photos of Danielle
follower
poetic heart hutchinson jr. shout outs
oh no no you read the part you sorry hey
Ryan can I get a shout out
I'm from Jamaica I can't do that how do
you do a Jamaican accent bon hello Mon
Oh British guy trying hey I know my
necks that cool man I'm also a poet and
I just didn't know it
oh right only in sad mood subscribe
today and become a rejecter okay I know
a girl who's solely ended Jamaicans
you're a poet that's so cool Richard the
poet wouldn't you know it he's a poet he
has a long song he likes to smoke out of
his bong and he emits when he's wrong as
he takes off the thong with his teeth
beneath the sheets as he makes love to
his darling wife for the rest of his
life camera cut can I tell with this
phone then he takes a knife and stabs
her twice no spits abs his wife serves
his wife wife oh I didn't rhyme it did I
no knife wife we can keep going okay
what do you mean
until the sun goes down on the red hound
and over the mound I heard a sound
sounds like a clone may I lay down you
have to at least make it into this God
is you're just rhyming at this body